Quên khách lúc sói của Nộ Kê Kối, Cột Điện và Tàn Phá hàng Lập nhà cửa tại Mỹ.
Hào CNN, cơ lốc hình thành vào Chio Hai Bại Tháng Bây,
Quách qua một phần thành phố Apotent và Mên A Sa, Bàng Uy Scasin.
Cơ quan thêm tiếp quốc gia Mỹ, phát cảnh bảo lúc sói cấp E2,
mất cảnh bảo cao thứ 2, với sức gió khoảng 2,000 km.
Trong khoảng 2,000 phút, cơ lốc làm tốt máy nhiều uy nhà, và hủy nhiều công chính, khoảng độ Kê Kối,
rồi gì chuyển qua hồ, quyết n bà gồm chức khi tàn trên mặt nước.
Chính quyền địa phương quyết n khá ngử dân ở trong nhà, đồng thời trên khai lực lượng cứ hộ nèng giá thiết hại và tìm kiếm nạn nhân.
Hơn bám nghiên hộ dân tạng tạng thạm thời mất địa.
Đến này, Chio Cột Thống Kê về thiết hại sò lúc sái khí ra.